bonsoir le 7-8 l'actus sur tv fil 78 le
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
de cette nouvelle édition de lundi à la
manif pour tous dénoncent la famille nos
phobies du gouvernement plusieurs
milliers de personnes dans les rues de
versailles ce dimanche après midi des
responsables politiques locaux étaient
présents et licenciements abusifs
complot suicides renault au coeur d'une
histoire surprenante le journaliste
matthieu suc a enquêté il publie aux
éditions du moment renault de nid
d'espions cela ressemble à un polar mais
tout ceci est il bien vrai nous le dira
tout à l'heure en plateau et puis en
sport week m de détection à
clairefontaine les meilleurs jeunes
footballeuses du département présente
pour séduire les entraîneurs des grandes
écoles américaines on débute par une
image de saison pour ne pas oublier de
rédiger votre lettre au père noël
d'autant qu'à magny les hameaux une
boîte aux lettres spéciale a été mise en
place pour recevoir vos correspondances
avec la laponie lé service enfance et
jeunesse ont réalisé conjointement cette
dernière qui se trouve à l'accueil de
l'hôtel de ville le secrétariat du père
noël répondra à chaque enfant qui aura
bien préciser ses nom prénom et adresse
sur son courrier politique municipale le
scrutin se déroulera en mars prochain et
l'association anticor association de
lutte contre la corruption et pour
l'éthique en politique et lance une
charte à l'attention des candidats
présentation de cette charte de ce texte
ce lundi dès 20h30 à poissy que contient
ce texte est à quoi va-t-il servir les
précisions de l'une des représentantes
d'anticorps
il y en a on a principalement précisé le
cumul des mandats sachant que le nombre
des mandats pour délit que son équipage
ont hélas calé sur le fait que cette
année peut-être et bûche son ami et
conseiller communautaire l'épée divers
donc partant de ce principe l'arbre
notre grille ans concernant la
particularité des morins c'est qu'on
peut être maires et présidents de
communautés de communes mémoire est
bonne on a une trentaine de signataires
vient pas en mesure de s'aligner dans
leur avait d'ailleurs j'habite dans le
loiret la première charte éthique je
veux montrer aux japonais nikkan parce
qu'on s'est aperçu que les contraintes
les deux cas il n'était pas tout à fait
les mêmes
les petits poissons pêchés quand même de
souvenirs que l'on risque de
déconfinement catalytique
peut-être plutôt des petits candidats
contrôler les engagements pris par les
maires ça va être chaque réplique au
bon maintenant effectivement très grave
attaque et vichy ont déjà un premier
temps on va leur demander gentiment de
respecter
les termes de l'engagement qu'ils ont
simulé mon choix et 12 non je veux pas
la respecter on les sort de rift soit il
se fait comme ça on l'a vu pour la
chaleur de la chanter diplomate yves
jégo non seulement il veut pas répéter
mais elle a deux qui s'étaient montrés
dans la presse qu'on aurait demandé de
respecter les termes de la charte en
étant assez et geraghty fonctionnement
du corps et là nous avons appliqué de
profit des
anticorps qui lance donc officiellement
sa charte pour les municipales pour les
différents candidats ce lundi soir
depuis poissy et dix mille personnes
selon la police 30 mille selon les
organisateurs il y avait en tout cas
beaucoup de manifestants dimanche dans
les rues de versailles à l'appel du
collectif manif pour tous une
manifestation pour dénoncer la family
phobie du gouvernement la députée ump
valérie pécresse ou encore le député et
nouveau président du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson étaient
présents catherine mulato et j'en
attends willeman une colère qu'il
voulait paisible mais tenace dans les
rues de versailles des milliers de
manifestants drapeaux français en main
ou étendard aux de la manif pour tous
les aujourd'hui leur mouvement dépasse
le cadre de la loi taubira en faveur du
mariage homosexuel
c'est le gouvernement tout entier et la
politique menée par françois hollande
qui est en ligne de mire les familles
françaises sont excédés là on a des as
attendre de loi qui établissent des
privilèges fiscaux des niches fiscales
pour le mariage dit accorder à tous les
couples et c'est un privilège fiscal
alors on est venu défendre couleurs
choses d'abord landry et donc le mariage
la parité homme femme dans le mariage et
puis également contre le gouvernement en
général
leur a confisqué à la latence la famille
sur l'éducation depuis le début du
mandat de françois eloy s'accumulent
contre la famille et aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être sa famille mais aussi fiscales
rencontre voilà dans l'économie c'est
une catastrophe certains n'hésitent pas
à parler destruction de la notion de
famille et fort d'un mouvement qui
semble très structuré voudrait jouer un
rôle lors des prochaines municipales
cette mobilisation ici aujourd'hui à
blois montpellier est là aussi pour
peser sur les élections ne pas dans une
dynamique partisane c'est le propre des
partis mais pour dire voilà entendit
nous écouter nous nous sommes le plus
grand mouvement social j'en ai réunion
en france depuis mai 68 le gouvernement
entend une sorte de sheer enchères il me
semble contre les familles ont laissant
entendre que finalement la famille est
là l'obstacle à la neutralité
républicaine et plus récemment on a eu
sur le plan fiscal des annonces ou en
tout cas des pré projet qui nous
inquiète avec une sorte de matraquage
fiscal spécifique aux familles de la
négation du quotient parente du quotient
familial
outre cette manifestation versaillaise
d'autres cortèges se sont déroulés à
bordeaux et montpellier avec toujours le
même slogan nous lâche rien
un anniversaire tout autre sujet le
lycée de villa roi à guyancourt qui
fêtait ses 20 ans ce week end l'occasion
de se remémorer quelques souvenirs mais
aussi d'évoquer les futurs projets de
l'établissement avec yolande thorez
séquence souvenirs et retrouvailles
devant les anciennes photos de classe le
lycée villa roi de guyancourt fêtait ses
20 ans ce week end certains font partie
des toutes premières promos de 160
élèves à avoir connu les préfabriqués
lors de cet anniversaire ils reviennent
quelques années en arrière
il ya eu pas de cantine donc fallait
tous les midis sortir prendre un bus
pour aller à des cas sauf que c'est à 2
minutes donc avec un prof oublié de vous
sortir heureusement qu'on était jeune le
nombre de fois dans l'année qu'on a fait
le parcours en courant y avait au moins
trois kilomètres pour savoir
paul autres lycées qui nous a accueillis
par des tonnes de choses à dire c'est
vraiment excellent exemple d'anecdotes
vous arrivez avec un contrôle donc on
n'a pas forcément tous leurs assauts
note j'ai dit fais voir tes réponses
soient correctement
toutes les bonnes réponses retourner le
voir à la fin je devais vous avez oublié
des points le problème c'est qu'on est
et 14 dans la classe sur 20 à faire ça
et vont 14 aurait il ajouté bien que
c'est pas lui qui a des preuves de
correction la toute première proviseur
du lycée ne comptait pas non plus rater
l'événement elle nous raconte l'un de
ses meilleurs souvenirs c'était le jour
de sa retraite un cadeau que lui avait
fait les élèves à l'époque il ya un
groupe d'élèves et vient me trouver et
qui me dit madame vous voudrez pose une
question
si c'était à refaire qu'est ce que vous
feriez et alors je leur dit spontanément
mais je referais la même chose et là
alors cadeau ça a été on en était sûrs
et ça ça m'a fait très plaisir je crois
que
finalement je pouvais partir j'avais
montré que j'aime et ce que je faisais
aujourd'hui l'établissement compte 850
élèves et plusieurs projets sont en
cours parmi eux l'ouverture d'une
spécialité qui n'existe que dans un
autre lycée des yvelines celle
d'architecturé construction skalli ces
si beaux quais à cette forme de comète
on a pensé qu'il était destiné à ouvrir
donc cette cette spécificité et on
espère qu'il attirera aussi des jeunes
film
est à noter que dans cet établissement
dès la prochaine rentrée sera proposée
une section lv3 arabe une information
qui fait écho à l'actualité de ce week
end avec ce rapport remis au premier
ministre et qui préconise justement est
l'étude de cette langue pour une refonte
de l intégration dans les établissements
scolaires au lycée de villa roi à la
proviseur précise qu'il n'est pas
forcément question de faire plaisir aux
parents on n'avait pas de langue 3 qui
potentiellement pouvait être offerte à
tous les élèves et du coup c'est parce
que c'est une longue et langue d'avenir
et est une langue qui mérite d'être
d'être connu et qu'il faut que les
élèves apprennent c'était aussi un choix
de plein de raisons y compris économique
on voit que c'est des pays en plein
développement que c'est des pays
partenaires des pays qui historiquement
sont liées à nous autour de la
méditerranée même quand on va en
andalousie on voit bien qu'il ya plein
de synergies a créé avec la culture la
culture à ce rapport sur l'intégration
rendue publique a fait beaucoup parler
du côté des politiques dans l'entourage
du premier ministre et du président on
reconnaît que sa publication sur le site
de matignon est une grave erreur il faut
dire qu'ils figurent notamment le retour
des signes religieux dans les
établissements scolaires au delà de
cette polémique comment faut-il agir
pour favoriser l'intégration dès l'école
c'est la question que nous avons posée
aujourd'hui vos réponses
peut-être faut-il qu'ils aient un peu
plus de soutien
scolaire parce que bon c'est pas évident
quand on vient d'un pays étranger mais
pour moi il ya il tend pas y avoir de
différence quoi il faut pas qu'ils
soient tous ensemble il faut que
ils soient dans plusieurs endroits de
manière à s'intégrer
manière beaucoup plus facile idéal c'est
qu'ils sont pris aux petits groupes et
qui commence par apprendre le français a
expliqué aux autres enfants aussi d'où
vient cet enfant là et expliquer un
petit peu ce qui se passe dans son pays
et puis qui se présente devant sa classe
est vraiment carnet sur ge avec les
autres les autres enfants déjà une
assistance pour leur permettre de
maîtriser le français et ça lui ça leur
permettrait de communiquer avec les
autres enfants
la fibre optique arrive dans la
communauté d'agglomération de versailles
le noeud de raccordement optique d'où
partiront les 30 km de fibre déployée
sur les villes de versailles viroflay et
le chesnay a été inauguré aujourd'hui
lundi le groupe sfr s'est vu attribuer
ce territoire par l'arcep l'autorité
nationale de régulation des
télécommunications premiers
raccordements opérationnel en juillet
prochain mais il faudra attendre 2020
pour couvrir l'ensemble du territoire
pour rappel ces installations
permettront d'avoir un débit 100 fois
supérieure à la technologie actuelle un
dispositif difficile à mettre en place
dans une ville telle que versailles
comme va nous l'expliqué le directeur
des relations régionales de sfr au micro
de claire cambier
c'est une ville qui est extrêmement
protégé du poilu son patrimoine et c'est
bien normal c'est ce qui fait aussi la
fierté des gens de manière donc vous
avez tout d'un cortège de gens à
commencer évidemment par les élus locaux
mais aussi les architectes des bâtiments
de france qui sont donc les garants de
l'intégrité évidemment de cette commune
en matière de protection des des
immeubles des monuments
ce que ça induit c'est que ça induit un
peu plus de temps à passer pour bien se
concerter et faire en sorte que le
mobilier que l'on va mettre dans la
ville les points de mutualisation
parce que là on aura un héros qui
al'avantage d'être enterrée mais les
autres équipes en sont souvent surface
il faut faire en sorte qu'on puisse les
intégrer le plus possible comment plus
versailles abrite une école design
caractères a donc l'idée c'est faire en
sorte de d'intégrer au lieu
effectivement ces équipements extérieurs
je demande avec des trompe l'oeil en les
fusionnant quelque part avec les
bâtiments alentour pour qu'il soit le
moins impactant le moins agressif
possible pour l'oeil et dont en même
temps l'idée si bien de préserver
effectivement l'intégrité de ce joyau
qui est l'amant la ville de versailles
l'invité de cette édition du 7 8 l'actus
et matthieu suc bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste indépendant ancien du
parisien et de france soir auteur de
antonio ferrara le roi de la belle ou
encore de la face cachée de franck
ribéry aujourd'hui nous allons parler
plutôt de renault avec ce nouvel ouvrage
renault et nids d'espions aux éditions
du moment une plongée une enquête dans
les coulisses de l'une des plus grandes
entreprises françaises entre fausses
accusations vrai coup monté et même
suicide un véritable polar sauf qu'ici
tout est bien réel cela se passe en
partie à deux pas d'ici au technocentre
à guyancourt on va commencer par
retracer cette histoire qui guide votre
livre 17 août 2010 un corbeau qui fait
parvenir à des dirigeants de
l'entreprise renault un courrier qui
accuse trois salariés de toucher des
pots-de-vins n'ayant divulgué des
informations secrètes du constructeur
concernant des projets de véhicules
électriques une enquête interne à des
buts ils sont licenciés seulement ils
nient leur implication pourquoi arnaud
décide alors de prendre autant au
sérieux cette affaire alors qu'on le
verra plus tard la société n'a aucune
preuve oui tout à fait ben en fait ça
c'est ce qui m'a intéressé dans le sujet
c'est que de montrer comment à partir de
rien ou presque parce que une entreprise
est soumis à une concurrence effrénée le
secteur automobile est très
concurrentiel il ya une graine une
paranoïa et donc à partir du moment où
vous faites une étincelle s'adonne
devient grand incendie et il y avait
simplement une escroquerie derrière la
faire c'est un renault a été soi même
victime
mais les dirigeants de renault ont leur
grande part de responsabilité dans le
marasme parce que ils se sont affolés
ils ont perdu toute sensation sur la
réalité tôt réagir on va voir quelques
images qui date de 2011 4 janvier c'est
une date importante
eric besson est alors ministre il est en
déplacement au technocentre à guyancourt
pour justement constater l les avancées
de renault sur l'électrique voilà les
images nous avions réalisé à l'époque
pour le journal de la rédaction la
veille les trois salariés ont donc été
licencié personne n'était au courant pas
même le ministre qu'il découvre comme
beaucoup de monde le soir même par une
dépêche de l afp une fuite dans la
presse on ne comprend pas pourquoi
renault n'a pas prévenu le ministre déjà
avant ce déplacement ni même prévenu les
le contre-espionnage français par
exemple là c'est alors sur l'exemple du
istres comme delà des séries donc le
service de contre espionnage français
c'est encore une fois c'est la paranoïa
c'est à dire que alors que l'état qui en
plus est actionnaire de renault et là
normalement pour aider surtout quand des
entreprises et des fleurons de
l'industrie sont supposés être victimes
d'attaqués extérieures l'état est là
pour les défendre renault se dit si on
le raconte à l'état ça va fuité dans la
presse et et puis qu'ils sont pas
forcément de l'autre côté ce qui est
assez bête comme réaction mais qu'il
démontre bien le côté enfermement de la
direction de renault est le fait on
pense en vase clos et on est seul contre
tous et les usa a monté sa propre
enquête en interne qui va utiliser ces
méthodes aussi de patinoire
tout à fait c'est à dire qu'on va enfin
renault va espionner les trois cadres
qu'il soupçonne eux mêmes de faire
l'espionnage on va vider leur ordinateur
et éplucher leurs mails y compris les
mails privés
personnels ce qui là est une infraction
on va se procurer leur ligne de
téléphone qui est ce qu'ils appellent
quand
vous avez réussi à mener cette enquête
justement 400 prat 400 pages de cet
ouvrage renault qui n'a pas souhaité
communiquer j'imagine que la direction
n'a pas participé à l'écriture c'est
tout va alors je les ai je les ai
contactés
pour leur soumettre bien sûr en
respectant le principe du contradictoire
renault a répondu à une ou deux
questions celle qui je pense les
déranger le moins et sur le reste s'est
retranché derrière le secret de
l'instruction ont vu qu'il ya une
affaire en cours je leur ai fait
remarquer que au moment de la faire ils
ont pas hésité à communiquer et des fois
un peu trop alors qu'il y avait un
secret de l'instruction est là à ce
moment là ça les gênait pas donc vous
avez élaboré cet ouvrage cette enquête
en allant rencontrer de bon nombre de
protagonistes 1 c'est un ouvrage très
complet on va continuer à évoquer ce
livre et avec une affaire que vous vous
en parlait dans cet ouvrage cette
affaire surprenante et tout le monde a
pu la constater c'est le pdg carlos
ghosn qui se rend au journal de tf1 qui
est invité et qu'ils l'affirment il a
des preuves mêlant qu'il n'a pas tout à
fait alors ça c'est l'aspect connu ce
dont tout le monde se rappelle ses
gaules qui va devant claire chazal et
qui dit devant des millions de gens
alors que c'est le moment où on commence
à comprendre que l'histoire n'est pas
aussi clair que ça et que les
affirmations de renault on comprend pas
très bien ce qu'il ya de derrière et
ghosn va dire si si on a des preuves
vous croyez quand même pas que j'ai viré
trois personnes si on n'était pas carrés
sur ce conte ce qu'on affirme ce qui
avec force très fort que quelqu'un comme
carlos ghosn patron d'une grande
entreprise tout le monde se disent s'ils
disent ah c'est sûr de lui a priori la
belle affaire quelques semaines après va
se déliter on va s'apercevoir que non et
la grande question que tout le monde se
pose c'est mais pourquoi il a été si
péremptoire et moi ce que je révèle dans
le livre c'est que au moment de monter
donc enfin quand il prend l'ascenseur
aura tour tf1 il est avec ses deux de
ces communicante il a fait un interview
le matin dans le jdd où il est très très
sobre dans la retenue y a rien qu'on
puisse lui reprocher il parle de la
ferme en étant vraiment sobre et là dans
l'ascenseur il dit non mais je vais dire
je vais des preuves parce que sinon je
vais passer pour un con ça peut faire
rire la phrase comme ça sauf que en même
temps quelques minutes plus tard il va
crucifier trois gars
noms sont sortis dans la presse et
pour les opinions publiques se dire bon
bah c'est vraiment des traîtres ça
aurait pu avoir des conséquences
dramatiques pour la vie de ces gens ont
ils ont été innocentés au final mais ce
qui se passe là ce que je relate la et
grave est-ce que vous rêvez révélé
également ce sont les méthodes employées
renault par exemple qui a rédigé après
le licenciement de ses trois salariés
des communiqués de presse en cas de
suicides de ses salariés ils réussissent
d'ailleurs ou non leur celui-ci l'aller
devait repousser le le cynisme selon moi
alors les gens qui font de la
communication disent non c'est pas du
cynisme c'est de la prévoyance chacun
jugera mais il avait poussé
effectivement le cynisme jusqu'à
préparer des communiqué en se disant ah
ils ont pas l'air d'être très bien en
les voyant des fois s'exprimer à la télé
il faudrait se suicider et il rédige les
communiqués avant même que les
licenciements soient prononcés il y
avait juste les blancs pour mettre les
noms la date et il y avait deux
communiqués un pur au cas où la personne
aurait réussi son suicide et seraient
donc décédées et l'autre il serait rater
au final qui a manipulé renault alors si
vous pouvez le dire aujourd'hui il ya
plusieurs choses il y a quelqu'un qui
est mis en examen pour escroquerie qui a
été un enquêteur interne de renault qui
a été licencié depuis qui lui proteste
de son innocence en disant qu'il était
lui-même
manipulé par d'autres personnes mais la
justice n'établit pas ça pour l'instant
donc lui l'aura répondre voix seulement
devant la justice donc à l'aspect
escroquerie et après il ya l'aspect il
ya un autre volet qui est la
dénonciation calomnieuse c'est à dire
quel est le corbeau qui est à l'origine
de cette affaire jean lalonde en
toujours pas on ne sait toujours pas il
ya aucun élément matériel c'était le
juge a vérifié les téléphones portables
de d'une quarantaine de protagonistes du
dossier pour voir si borné à l'endroit
où la lettre a été déposé on n'arrive
pas à voir
le début de commencement de preuve et
l'aspect aussi des responsabilités au
sein de la direction de renault c'est à
dire que il ya l'aspect escroquerie mais
après renault a comme commandité des
actes rassemblements illégaux il ya des
gens qui devront en répondre c'est tout
un système que vous dénoncez vous parler
de cette affaire renault mais pas
seulement de cette affaire vous parlez
aussi de ses enquêtes sur la vie privée
de syndicalistes d'ailleurs est encore
une plainte qui est instruite
actuellement sur d exfiltration aussi de
salariés qui travaillaient à moscou on
leur fait croire qu'ils seraient
victimes potentielles d'attentats
tchétchène une fois en france ils sont
licenciés pour corruption et puis il ya
ces suicides au technocentre renault sur
le site du technocentre renault de 7
salariés
aujourd'hui ce système existe encore
alors renault affirme que non qu'ils ont
tiré toutes les conséquences de
leurs dérives passées qu'ils ont mis
alors ça c'est la seule chose ils n'ont
pas voulu je rencontre les gens à qui
j'avais des questions à poser par contre
ils m'ont proposé de rencontrer des gens
qui n'étaient pas dans la ferme et qui
sont les nouveaux patrons de la sécurité
pour expliquer à quel point maintenant
c'est une entreprise modèle sur ce qu'on
sait pour l'instant a priori il n'y a
pas grand chose
à reprocher après il ya deux ou trois
ans on m'aurait pour m'auriez posé la
question je vous aurais dit bah écoutez
a priori non c'est l'histoire qui nous
le dira mais pour l'heure je peux pas
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus marqué en
tout cas au cours de votre enquête je
pense aussi à cette affaire ce stagiaire
chez renault que l'on emmène de nuit
piraté les ordinateurs des salariés vous
attendiez à trouver sur ce genre de ce
genre de système alors oui ça c'est ça
c'est un élément qui en dit long et qui
était bien avant qu'ils étaient avant
l'arrivée de carlos ghosn qu'est ce qui
veut dire aussi que c'est un système qui
a ancré moi je rapporte des histoires et
je replace le la sphère dont a parlé
dans un contexte qui s'étend sur 10 ans
parce qu'en fait cette entreprise va
devenue une zone de non droit mais
progressivement c'est vrai que je vous
raconte enfin c'est un enfin un
adolescent qui vient faire un stage
d'automobiles les barbus du service de
sécurité découvre qu'il est vrai trop
mauvaise influence sur l'informatique et
ils l'emmènent de nuit à 4h du mat sur
les sites industriels de renault pour
forcer les disques durs d'un salarié qui
plus est
représentants du personnel donc ce qui
est ce qu'il vaut là je le révèle aussi
c'est que deux ans étant mis à six
personnes de chez renault qui ont été
mises en examen dans ce volet là
beaucoup de révélations autour de cet
ouvrage juste pour conclure le préciser
que vous serez pour une séance de
dédicaces pour un débat au pavé du canal
à montigny le bretonneux le 18 décembre
mercredi de 17 heures à 19 heures et
pour la petite histoire ce rendez-vous
est née de la forte demande des salariés
de renault qu'il souhaitait vous
rencontrer tout à fait il y avait une
bourse aux livres chez au technocentre
de renault et j'ai appris fortuitement
que mon livre
était parti en deux jours que les
libraires on a commandé il était débordé
c'était le livre que tout le monde
s'arrachait et donc on j'ai contacté le
libraire il était ravi m'a proposé tout
de suite parce qu'il se doutait que les
salariés on va envie de me voir et donc
ce sera mercredi 18 décembre si vous
souhaitez en savoir encore plus sur cet
ouvrage matthieu suc merci d'être passé
sur ce plateau hauteur de renault ni
d'espions éditions du moment si vous
aimez le polar bien sûr c'est à lire
même si tout cela est vrai on le
rappelle c'est une enquête
journalistique
un autre sujet qui vous passionne
également ses de football et on va
parler à présent nous d'une détection à
clairefontaine c'était ce week end ou
même paris soccer show l'occasion pour
des jeunes joueuses françaises les
yvelinoises de bon un niveau sportif et
scolaire d'obtenir une bourse pour
évoluer au pays du football féminin vous
allez le voir avec ce sujet d' anthony
rech
faustine évolue en division d'honneur
régionale avec montigny le bretonneux à
18 ans elle rêve du championnat de
soccer américain comme pour la
cinquantaine d'autres joueuses présentes
ce week-end à clairefontaine cette
détection et peut-être sa meilleure
chance de venir fouler un jour ce
terrain avec l'équipe de france c'est
une bonne opportunité pour partir à
l'étranger déjà et puis les états unis
c'est un peu le pays du foot féminin
donc voilà c'est toujours bon à prendre
ce genre d'opportunité faut pas là il
faut pas la louper quoi sur la droite du
milieu de terrain camille quelque peu
stressé par la présence des recruteurs a
dû s'adapter aux exercices tactiques à
l'américaine c'est à peu près similaire
après c'est vrai que c'est vraiment au
niveau de l'intensité mois que j'ai
trouvé un changement où ils nous en
demande beaucoup plus et enfin faut
vraiment ya pratiquement aucune pause
enfin deux entre les nids les exercices
comme il demande beaucoup de physique
d'intensité et tout est ce que en france
on a beaucoup moins apparemment et c'est
vrai que c'est fatigant mais ça va ça ça
tient pour attirer les meilleurs
éléments du week-end la plupart des
universités sont prêtes à prendre en
charge la majorité de leur cursus en
moyenne 200 mille euros sur quatre ans
et la vingtaine de recruteurs présents
au bord du terrain semble avoir repéré
quelques talents de weave sync
j'ai pu voir des joueuses techniquement
très intéressante et certaines possèdent
également des qualités athlétiques et un
jeu plus rapide qui leur permettrait
d'avoir un beau parcours dans notre
programme universitaire
malgré des actions intéressantes lors de
l'opposition et un but marqué par
faustine les deux joueuses
saint-quentinoise n'ont pas obtenu
d'entretiens individuels pour espérer
continuer l'aventuré outre atlantique et
pour un point complet sur le sport le
7-8 sport avec anthony rech c'est chaque
lundi 18h30 pour la première diffusion
nous on termine ce journal comme on l'a
commencée avec une histoire de père noël
c'est l'opération parvis en fait qui se
tenait ce samedi à magny les hameaux
plusieurs stands étaient proposés sous
le regard bien attentionnés du père noël
et ça tombe bien les enfants avait
forcément des choses à lui commander et
il est apparu comme une rockstar sur le
toit de la mairie de magny les hameaux
le père noël bien entendu bonjour forme
du moment les regards d'enfants
totalement émerveillé l'occasion de leur
demander ce qu'ils ont justement
commandé au père noël
voitures télécommandées
spiderman un chat avec une maison de ce
truc des animations tout au long de la
journée stands maquillage création de
décorations de noël et un spectacle tout
en poésie pour terminer ce parvis en
fait avec les allumeurs des toiles
et puis aux chiffres encore un retenir
un chiffre très important plus de 500
barbe à papa ont été distribués ce
samedi
attention aux overdoses de sucre le
journal revient mardi 18h très bonne
soirée sur téléphiles